welcome to this video game two of the
World Championship match in chennai
india we had a very short draw yesterday
if i recall correctly 16 or 17 moves one
of the shortest draws in World
Championship history so let's hope that
today's game Game two with Island
playing white would be an yeah more
interesting affair let's get right to
the moves island is right playing a 1.e4
no surprise but you never know him in
recent watch championship matches both
in ball against kramnik against to pawn
off and also against the girl found he
had plated d4 frequently so it wasn't
100% clear that he would play as old
favorite but before is the moose and the
first surprise comes on with one by
black here by cards are playing c6 the
calc on he has played this before but i
only found less than 10 games in the
database i think seven games eight games
something like that and he am very much
favors 1e5 and 1c five him varies
between those two moves and okay modern
modern assessments monetary is mostly
saying that if ivan c5 are the best
moves causes even on record having said
that we considers all moves besides II 5
and see 45 a second-rate okay but c6 is
of course a viable opening you've seen
me play dat many times and blitz chess
c6 okay the Calcutta and Island goes for
93 this is some his usual way to to
combat the calcaneus played a couple of
advanced lines advanced nike5 but Knight
c3 ISM the most common continuation in
his some games if you have watched my
pre World Championship Series the 20
games 10 by each player's you might have
seen the game aren't against Pune I off
from the early 2000s 2003 I guess not
mistaken where does she played a very
nice positional game in the and the main
line here okay 93 and cards on taking
money form and playing Bishop f5 pretty
much the only continuation played
nowadays on the top level for some
reason 97 which is still very solid
isn't played that off and I guess 95 is
becoming more and more of a problem yeah
but I guess Bishop fif is the main move
anyway 93 bishop g6 and now aged for
this is the only i'll move to be
considered dangerous really white can
play other lines like let's say nitey 22
a form or i can start with Bishop c4
here and then try to arrest the bishop
with Knight to f4 but those lines are
very much out of fashion almost all top
players go 4h 4m yeah h6 the only move
needs to secure a place for the bishop
and now Knight f3 it's important to note
that the move h5 here very often played
mostly by over two players as a serious
yeah mistake is a bit much but it's not
the most accurate move the reason is
after Bishop age 79 f3 that black can
play e 6 cm and delay the move 97 this
is a bit similar to the game but White
has played h4 h5 you would see in the
game that black basically has won a move
here this kind of position with c5 to
come is some as very nice for black
actually let's compare this to the gamer
maybe it's getting more clearer than the
game nida 3 first was played and now
cars and played e6
this is in fact a bit of a rare move the
normal movie has 97 the ideas with 97 to
prevent the immediate 95 because of the
capture and change a 5 picking up the
important d5 pawn this is why 97 is the
most popular move because black does not
like to face this early night jump to e5
but it 6 has a particular idea the ideas
after 95 gaining this temple bishop age
7 Bishop d3 and this kind of
continuation to delay the moves is 65 on
and said let's aim to not play 97 early
so that you have the opportunity to play
quick see 5 or maybe play Knight to c6
here if you compare this to the line I
showed before with the early age 5 this
is very similar after Knight f6 with the
intention of playing c5 but why does not
played h4 h5 so black has basically
gained a mafia it's a bit difficult to
tell although some yeah subtle points
apart Townsend didn't play Knight f6 it
can easily transpose he played 97 first
and aren't responded with F form yeah a
form trying to support the night only
five this allows mostly to capture it
with the f porn in case black gown would
take it it gains space but it also it
also puts many pawns on dark squares
also the edge hope on which means that
you need to be a bit cautious with your
bishop on c1 the more points you put on
dark squares the more problematic this
Bishop might become a long run okay what
should like do now thousand once play
Bishop e7 and Knight f6 but
he first place check the nice move
Bishop b4 Czechia where this a nice move
and black ones to play Bishop e7 anyway
but this check is quite annoying for
might you don't really want to play
Bishop d2 and allow exchanges this would
help like because this is a bit cramped
so why play C 3 and now we chance to be
seven and okay Black has gifted white
the move c3 but this is actually
something that black likes to see this
move because with f4 and h4 is pretty
clear that white will not Castle short
anymore and on long castling c3 might be
a weakening of the king and it's another
pawn on the dark square so black has
accomplished a little something with
this check yeah now h4 is hanging but
island is ignoring this maybe I'm Bishop
h4 we should have a quick look at why is
this move risky yeah if everything else
fails and white can take on this heaven
and now as the Queen has to guard the
bishop the king must recapture and I
guess that's enough to persuade blacker
not to not to go into this from a mere
pawn you have the King on d7 and I fear
that there may be even more forceful
reputations this low and what it no
black should go for that he just played
90 f6 good and simple move and aren't
now with the long castles yeah in fact
this position before long castles I not
already had played earlier and he played
Queenie 2 in this game that I found so
long castles is some in the World
Championship some game history is a new
move but of course a move that certainly
Carden could have reckoned with if you
look at the use time the times are
fairly accurate it's just a matter of
couple of
seconds off for both players you see
that do she was playing relatively
quickly but causal was basically
blitzing the moves he played everything
instantly so he was very well expecting
this position of course easy to expected
it had played it before so what did Carl
play now he played just short castles
and yeah now we come to one point of the
game after the short castles where I can
explain why I don't play the classical
cattle cars black simply because all the
modern lines involve short castling and
I always get real yeah nervous if if I
have to castle with h6 being played and
I always imagined ok he will move the
night away and then g4 and g5 and I made
so I'm yeah I'm a bit of a yeah always
too nervous in this kind of positions
but nowadays short castling isn't
considered to be so risky in this type
of position so Carlton didn't hesitate
long to Castle short I guess in this
position now we need to I mean here's
this piece the position where white
could try to to play for more than what
he got in the game he played night
before him after about 10 minutes
thinking time the question is some what
else is there white could certainly try
to make this g four at once work and
this is also why he played 90 for this
in general terms the night on g3 is not
particularly well placed and you can try
to to move it and then push the Jeep on
for example if you want to examine
something else besides 94 you could
think about 92 but the question is amiss
quick enough for white to to gain
anything substantial yet g4 is of course
the idea what should like do
one thing to consider is the very
mechanical answer h5 tried to fix pawns
on them on the dark squares and stopping
g4 for the moment which at the moment
could just be taken and still may be
along these lines is where why should
should try to make any progress it's
difficult however if you let's say Queen
a free for instance and tending g4 then
you even have to reckon with the capture
on e5 and Nigerian this briefly and with
the night on g4 white will never play
his pawn to g4 so it's a complicated
position so maybe around here is the way
to to look for improvements 94 it's not
a bad move it just seems to be a bit too
tame to really go for anything
substantial Carlton took now only five
logical move in fact then what you need
to do is you need to also examine night
xe5 this is an alternative the point is
that after F takes d5 we get the game
position but the right could not static
about taking here the interesting point
is after Bishop f6f takes d5 the
question is what should like do now
taking on edge form is a risky decision
and and you can also think about this
move because okay it's a pin here right
of course after Bishop takes doesn't
need to capture he can play this count a
sec and okay this is an interesting line
but why should black allow those kind of
things on new 15,000 solution is much
clearer he just took on e4 as mentioned
white recaptures and then the CAPTCHA
only five so we get all Knights of the
board and white now takes with the f
porn the very logical decision you open
up your bishop
and they capture towards the center you
can also think about d text in five but
in this concrete position the problem
could be that after Queen t5 again this
move this combined the tech on a two
when the Queen basically forces the
trade and then we get to an end game
which is similar to them to the game but
the White has a pawn on f4 and it's
questionable if this is in any way
attractive to him especially if you
consider that black again has this
counter play I don't know I think the
game is better in comparison we see
after FTSE 525 it's quite similar white
no needs to trade because it Wang's so
we have to trade and Carson on
recaptures with the see Paul yeah
capturing towards the center and having
this idn winter it's a type of minority
attack on the queenside so we have an
end game and we should put the next move
on the board this is in fact a very
important boost and to move that um yeah
amateur players can easily miss but it
becomes second nature to you once you
have understood the ideas behind it and
I know plate and very quickly played h5
and this is as mentioned in almost
automatic move in the structure but
white tries to do is to fix those two
points G&H pawn on dark squares so that
his bishop can attack it right take them
two points attack them in the long run
very deep until the bishop endgame those
pawns can be a target if white would not
go for that play some some slow moves
that lets say something like that black
will play h5 and prevent that and we'll
fix even more pawns on
squares this is also why wyd wants to go
h5 putting this on a light square and
making sure that he has some some points
at least to attack in the long run the
light squarepants f7 e65 obviously will
never be attacked by the bishop so when
we have a position here that it's um
yeah I guess balance simply because
black in the long run enjoys a good
minor piece on his heaven but he suffers
from the lack of space white has this
cramping pawn on e5 and those two
factors somewhat cancel each other out
black of course also has be fast before
this kind of attack trying to inflict a
week for Nancy three the thing is the
issue with the bad bishops with this
kind of Bishop where you always read
okay are they honor the same color
complex as those pawns this is not
really a bad bishop and in the very true
sense of the word because white enjoy
such a big space-based advantage if you
have a space advantage this becomes less
important that you are pushing this on
the same color complex simply because
with this much space it's difficult for
the other side to enter your position if
you imagine this position with all rooks
off then how should black make any sort
of progress you can push the King to c6
play b5 and white just sit in weights
and nothing basically will ever happen
the problem with those bad bishops is if
you have also if you suffer from from
the lack of space for example if you
would have this position here with white
having a bishop on d3 and black Bishop
on d7 and no dark squared Bishop then
what would be very much better because
he's got the good Bishop begins the bed
Bishop and black suffers from from lack
of space this position is probably just
equal
let's see what happened Calvin's plays a
b5 starting his call to play on the
queenside and yahoo cage three very
typical using the rook on the third rank
here or here a5 and rook f1 yeah these
are the lines where white white rocks
can operate the eff file and later
possibly the G file yeah rook c8
intending before and now rook g3 was
played yeah and in this position White
has a very simple idea obviously just
bishop age six yeah and what should like
do very easy solution you need to move
the king obviously king 2h7 now on a
plate Group G 2 m3 attacking f7 and yeah
if you haven't seen the game before a
nasty suspicion might creep into your
mind yes you need to cover this pawn and
the best way to do it is actually King
g8 and now the she played group g3 and
the job you we had this before teenage
them yet unfortunately exactly that
happened here the game was drawn so we
have yet another draw rather quick draw
25 moves and yeah bit of a disappointing
start of the match you always like to
see a little bit of blood on the board
and of those kind of yeah bit of a
lifeless draw however if you look at the
position similar to 22 yesterday it's a
rather understandable decision what
exactly should black for instance do in
this position here you need to fight
Bishop h6 you only have the skin move
and after this look to f3 and the tech
of this pawn king g8 is simply the best
move black could try f6 just to put it
on the board
but after the capture we see that this
didn't really help like this on polony
six is not exactly great it was very
nicely protected before and now white
could try to increase pressure on this
bond and you don't really have any
particular game besides the fact that
it's not a draw you haven't gained
anything you continue the game but this
is basically playing for loss not that
he's in big trouble but to get to take
this can of risk is black is really only
a card for if you desperately need to
win so what should like do very hard to
avoid the draw if we look at this
position look we have three King g8 and
let's say they wouldn't have drawn here
you can now it's a technical draw
because of 34 repetition but let's say
white would go for another plan playing
g4 and g5 this is some something that
white can try and basically the only
thing that white can try there is no
other pawn break in the position left
and this is very often an indication
that a position becomes draw if there's
no useful porn break in a position how
do you actually improve it based on
pieces alone it's difficult with only
this kind of half open file for each
side so g4 is basically the only idea
that blacker ya can face him let's say
before counter play and now I'm Brooke
g1 and 1085 I just want to show that
like has very useful counter play and
this is just a week pawn note that white
already has a clear we porn while black
has no such thing he's just trying to
justify his play with g5 but this is all
he has let's try that g5 like takes
check yeah just to to show the general
idea and now I'm
gap there are more than one possible
it's more than one possible way to play
black can also just try to immediately
initiate counter play with Roxy 8 and
yeah why it needs to react to that and
yeah here it's a matter of calculation
already black and can take on d4 and
something to consider let's say rook to
g3 and now let's have a look at this
kind of line like we'll get enough
counter play it's a simply a delicately
balanced position um yeah maybe they
should have yeah played this kind of
line out to to show that it's a draw but
it's it's simply taking a bit of risk
that is can be can really backfire in
such a match as mentioned white already
has a clear weakness Iran's III and if
something goes wrong in your counter
play here with g5 you might end up worse
so I understand the decision to to go
for the draw it's a bit of the it's it's
a safety-first approach but this kind of
match format with 12 games really means
that losing is not too comfortable you
only have a couple of games to come back
so drawers are not the best not the
worst result possible if you're in a
position where not much is happening
it's probably just wiser to take a draw
than to to gamble on something that
basically isn't there alright so
tomorrow monday and will be a rest day
so we'll be back on Tuesday with Game
three cards and again playing white and
I personally expect and that you will
play you for on move run in Game three
and not Knight f3 g3 again this very
cautious opening with white by Carson um
it's not uncommon in World Championship
matches you often see that the first
game is played really cautiously because
you really don't want to do something
stupid and lose the
game if you remember for instance
Kramnik in bond 2008 the first game they
had a slap on the board and coming
Kramnik actually played the exchange
sloth and basically did nothing as white
just trading pieces and trying for new
something that never was there yeah not
the most exciting decision but it's
probably good match tactics to not
reveal your cards too early and just
play it safe in the first game all right
let's hope for the spectators point of
view that the third game will be more
spectacular thanks for watching I'll be
back on Tuesday